let's talk a little more about the
events that happen on
january 6th
so there has recently been some cell
phone
location data leaked that shows
that these [ __ ] idiots that attended
donald trump's
rally that incited the violence on
january 6
that led them to march on the capitol
that there is proof that they did so
because despite these morons not wanting
to get a vaccine because
they think bill gates has implanted a
microchip in it
these [ __ ] shit-eating morons had
their cell phones
not only in their pockets but they had
them on
and we've seen all the footage that they
filmed
themselves
but not to mention the hidden data that
is locked inside these phones
that these [ __ ] boneheads have no
idea exist
they go on and on and on about how the
vaccines got a computer chip in it and
it's gonna play mind control and your
horns are gonna grow out of your ass or
some stupid [ __ ] because they don't want
to be tracked
but yet they get on parlor
and they they tweet on parlor
they go live on facebook and youtube
and mewi and gab
and they have their cell phones with the
computer chip tracking them the entire
[ __ ] way
to washington during the rally
marching all the way up to the capitol
then going inside
and all this evidence is going to be
used in court against these dumb [ __ ]
every single bit of it
you're you're not gonna see one of them
one of them denying oh
oh my i wasn't there my cell phone was
there but i wasn't there
it grew [ __ ] legs and walked down the
street i swear to god
come on people
and we're worried about a microchip and
a [ __ ] vaccine are you kidding me
these are the people we're supposed to
listen to about a computer chip
and a [ __ ] vaccine that somehow bill
gates and
anthony fauci invented the coronavirus
as
some worldly plot to take down donald
trump years in advance
that way at the right [ __ ] moment
they could release it in wuhan
china so that way it would make its way
to the united states and take down
donald trump
and then bill gates would make a vaccine
and put it in your arm and [ __ ] track
you
from now until kingdom gum what
so that it we could get rid of donald
trump
and at the rally where the last nail is
going in the coffin into donald trump
you [ __ ] morons have a
computer chip in your [ __ ] pocket at
a rally where he
ralls you up to go try to stop him from
taking him down
and you carry it all the way to the
capitol giving the fbi every single
piece of [ __ ] information they need
to know about you
and that what tracking they need from
you
you can't make this [ __ ] up and i'm it's
possible it's possible that there's
gonna be dozens
and dozens and dozens of movies made
from this
some will be documentaries on how
[ __ ] dumb these people are
and how [ __ ] gullible and stupid and
delusional they were and some will be
fiction
that won't even be able to capture the
[ __ ] truth
[ __ ] them